You know, this this is super interesting. The
great investigative reporter, Gabriel Sherman
published a piece in Vanity Fair yesterday which
says that although everybody around Donald Trump
is publicly talking about he's doing so great,
he's leaving the hospital. He's powerful. He did
it. He did it all. Donald Trump Junior reportedly
recognizes that Trump's behavior is completely
outrageous and believes that they need to do an
intervention on his dad. Gabriel Sherman writing
that, according to a source he spoke to, Don
Junior is deeply upset by Donald Trump's decision
to do the Corona Caravan drive around Walter Reed
on Sunday. One of the sources said to Gabriel
Sherman, Chairman Don Junior thinks Trump is
acting crazy. Don Junior told friends that he went
to a VANKA and Eric Trump and Jared Kushner and
said, we have to stop Dad from acting so unstable
and that he wants an intervention, but that
Jared Kushner and Yvonne, could Trump keep
telling Trump, you're doing great. You're just
doing great. You're killing it, Dad. Don Junior
is said to be reluctant to confront his father
alone, saying, quote, I'm not going to be the
only one to tell him he's acting crazy. After
Donald Trump on Monday morning sent out more than
what was it, a dozen, 15, 20, all caps tweets the
Trump Tril children did say to people they would
prefer Trump stop tweeting. According to a source
close to the family, quote, They're all worried.
They've tried to get him to stop tweeting. As you
know, Donald Trump has been prescribed medications
which medical experts agree can impair cognitive
function, affect mood, euphoria, mania, delusions
of grandeur. And this is actually something
I want to talk to Anthony Scaramucci about.
Are people afraid of confronting Trump about
anything? Does this explain why he keeps saying
the 1917 flu? He keeps saying plasma instead of
plasma. And there's a super interesting paragraph
in the Vanity Fair piece which says, quote,
There is a long history in the Trump family
of denying serious illness. According to a Trump
family friend, Trump's father, Fred Trump senior,
insisted on working even after his Alzheimer's
disease advanced in the 1990s to retire
is to expire. Fred Senior would say the friends
said that as Fred Senior's disease worsened,
he once came down this. There's wearing
three neckties. The family created a system
so that Fred could think he was still running
the Trump Organization every day Fred Senior
would go to his office in Brooklyn. They would
give him blank papers to sort through and sign
the phone on. Fred's desk was set up so that it
could only dial his secretary. Fred pretended to
work. The family friend said Trump's hopped up on
euphoria and mania inducing steroids and making
very poor decisions on a day to day basis. Maybe
something similar is going to be put in place in
case in point. In theory, in principle, Trump can
still make decisions about not launching nuclear
weapons. We know that Richard Nixon, when he was
under the influence of drugs for at least part
of his presidency, there was a system where the
defense secretary told the military commanders
do not take Richard Nixon's orders without
somebody else in a senior position endorsing it.
Has something similar been put in place with
Donald Trump? We don't know. But even Don Junior,
who does not always seem to be having his wits
about him himself, very often when we see him on
video, even Don Junior recognizing some of what's
going on, wanting an intervention, which from
everything we know is not going to happen.
Let me know what you think. I'm on
Twitter at David Pakman. We have
so much more to discuss today.